do you guys know that texting is causing
stress
everyone thinks that it's making your
life easier but it's actually killing
you from the inside that's right
researchers at Washington and Lee
University have found there's a
correlation between texting and stress
levels and texting and quality of sleep
I actually have started a thing where
for a half-hour before I go to bed I'm
off the phone believe it or not I
actually stopped tweeting for a few
minutes before I go to sleep this
doesn't surprise me that much actually
you researchers found the people who
send the most text messages experienced
the most sleep problems and a higher
number of daily text was associated with
more sleep problems let's look at some
more info people who sent a lot of text
sleep worse because they feel pressure
to reply to text in the middle of the
night they sleep with the phone by their
bed so they're awoken by incoming texts
and people who communicate by text have
more stress in their friendships texts
are unable to convey the nuance is
important in discussing sensitive issues
that that all seems pretty obvious to me
and I think we've all done that where
you you you send a tweet or a text or
something right before bed and then I
call did anyone respond or did this
person respond right and then it's it's
actually in your dreams it starts
burrowing its way into your brain how
much does this stuff affect you I think
it came to me at a point later in my
life where I don't think about it when I
sleep I can still get kind of grumpy and
farty about some things to pull me out
of it but there's times when I realized
I am reshaping the musculature of both
my hands yeah and now your people the
thumb as opposable as it as supposed to
be was never meant to do micro work like
this and people got and Cameron Diaz on
the set of bad teacher showed me a trick
for for texting from it take your finger
here and you take your hand here you go
click and you push back like that and it
pops the bone back feels like neck crack
good in your hand and that also we can
be invaded by aliens right now when we'd
have no idea cuz no one looks up
everyone's in a conversation just not
with the people near them yeah how
dangerous do you think texting is really
because losing that nuance and losing
just the eye contact and little things
that go on when you're talking to
somebody that
we're becoming cold aren't we through
through texting I think it's interesting
they focus on texting on this and right
we're talking about tweeting and we're
talking about Facebook statuses they're
just talking about your interpersonal
communication with people who you
assumedly know right who actually unlike
exactly right which is the bio feedback
loop you get if I sent a tweet and oh my
god anyone answer and if I'm wanting to
check it that tick to see um so I think
with this it's interesting cuz that it's
a chicken or egg situation were these
the same type of people that before
texting were the type of people that had
to have their boyfriend call them in the
middle the night to let them know they
were home or these the people that are
already worried about where their
children are constantly are these people
gonna be consistently feel the need to
be connected or need to know what's
going on with everyone in their social
circle anyway or these just stress
people that would be stressing about
what time for breakfast tomorrow what to
where it's just replacement stress if I
am I getting a text or not so you know I
think in this situation yeah texting you
can say that this makes you more
miserable and they may have isolated to
texting but I'd like to see the other
habits of these people or what they did
before texting existed that probably
kept them up at night anyway
yeah there's got to be some sort of
correlation between people that can't
sleep because of worry and anxiety and
people that are consistently texting but
young kids I love to see the ages on
this because if it's kids that didn't
have anything before texting it really
interesting to see if this is a new
stress in their life right so is part of
the problem here also event yeah that
you're willing to say things on text
that you wouldn't say to someone in
person you know what I mean because of
you losing all that nuance your you can
be more direct that's why I have a
general thing like I only text really
for directions or I'm standing on this
corner come meet me or something you
know like I don't have the
conversational text I hate the common
way that once you put it in writing
someone has ever I'm gonna say some
crazy [ __ ] to you you bet it's gonna be
in person not crazier things via text
message I am like what is wrong with you
don't you understand that's in writing
somebody can tweet out your text
messages people could put facebook a
threat to you ago you just put in fruits
of everyone know you're the your your
suspect one if anything happens you can
see like
no I copied the page already right this
whole thing on Facebook that was pretty
kind of gnarly who's hitting on me and
then when I didn't really reciprocate it
turned into this nasty thing and I told
them of his friends about and they're
like man and he would never do that in
person and I was like well then he's
really stupid cuz I just screengrab the
whole entire thing in one second it
could be everywhere I didn't go in there
Julie because I was like gosh I don't
wanna be involved in this um but I mean
wouldn't you say to me that doesn't make
any sense you're gonna say something in
person then then you'd be crazy right so
there's a little of this that none of us
grew up on this we're not 14 and when I
was reading this article I kept thinking
of that scene in Downton Abbey where the
Dowager Countess sees electricity for
the first time the light turns on and
she freaks out like this is a little bit
of that with us because we didn't grow
up on it so there's this inherent fear
of new things even though there's
everyone has new things when they grow
up and it usually doesn't destroy the
generation life just keeps rolling on
people's that television is ruining
society because everyone's parked in
front of the boob tube and you're on
your TV and now people are parked in
front of the YouTube and they're you
know watching their computer and then
people are parked in front of their
phone their text messaging so every
generation has their Elvis or has their
this thing is too wild for us or too
damaging for us and then you know who
knows maybe little people you're playing
with your hologram is so dangerous
because don't have any real friends it's
everything progresses to different
cities and not to totally blow your mind
folks but we are taping this at YouTube
and you're watching on YouTube well
hey guys the Reuben report is brought to
you by Cooper comm they've got 75% off
dog and cat choose toys accessories home
goods and more use code RR for 20% off
your next purchase the link is right
down there